good morning Hank it's Tuesday I've been
thinking a lot about Kylie Jenner by the
way this is a story in which no one is
telling the entire truth including me
but right I've been thinking a lot about
Kylie Jenner I don't want to be exactly
but I went on reddit and I saw this post
with 129,000 upvotes titled Kylie Jenner
thinks she owns the phrase rise and
shine highly upvoted comments included
can we fundraise to countersue and
hundreds of other angry take downs and
literally no one pointing out that this
entire story was fictional then again
generous response to the story was a
little misleading okay so I guess at
some point Kylie Jenner said rise and
shine in a funny way that got
extensively me methide and then Jenner
quickly released some merch which by the
way is exactly what I would do if
something I said were viewed a billion
times on Tik Tok but anyway then TMZ
reported that Jenner's company had filed
to trademark the phrase rise and shine
in the context of cosmetics and clothing
and people got rather upset but the
thing to remember is that trademarking a
phrase is not the same thing as owning
the phrase like Nike did not invent the
idea of just doing it and indeed Shia
LaBeouf is not infringing on Nikes
trademark when he says he would only be
infringing on Nikes trademark if he said
just do it in certain contexts like the
marketing of sports where context
similarly if Kylie Jenner trademarked
the phrase rise and shine I could still
annoy my children by saying rise and
shine every morning I just couldn't
start a cosmetics line called rise and
shine that is of course assuming the
trademark applications are approved
which they might not be because several
other companies already have rise and
shine related trademarks which
presumably Jenner's lawyers knew about
because they are also seeking to
trademark these somewhat less common
phrase rise with three eyes and shine
with five total vowels and then just as
outrage about these trademark
applications is growing the Gold Coast
bulletin in Australia publishes a story
claiming that a small t-shirt company
that sells rise and shine t-shirts has
received a cease and desist letter from
Kylie Jenner this is the story that
became a tweet that got screenshotted
and became a reddit post that got a
hundred twenty nine thousand up votes
and it is entirely false it has been
denied not just by Jenner but also by
the Australian t-shirt company how did
this story get published idol
no maybe a source exaggerated maybe
there was a miscommunication the real
question is how come I only read one
story in the Gold Coast bulletin this
year and it was that one right like the
problem is that I am much more likely to
click on their inaccurate news than on
their accurate news assuming they have
any I know nothing about the outlet so
then Jenner says on Twitter I have not
sent any rise and shine cease and desist
letters rise and shine was an unexpected
moment I had a lot of fun with it and I
have laughed so hard seeing everyone's
memes which is an amazing statement and
was definitely vetted by a lawyer that
statement does an amazing job of
avoiding the fact that should those
trademark applications be granted
Jenner's company will be required by law
to send lots of cease and desist letters
including potentially to small companies
selling rise and shine t-shirts if you
have a trademark you are not legally
allowed to selectively enforce it and
you have to enforce it otherwise you
lose the trademark this is why as
explained elsewhere Hank and I have
never trademarked the phrase don't
forget to be awesome
or the initialism dftba in short
trademark law is complicated I said at
the beginning I wasn't going to tell the
whole truth and I haven't even this
video has radically oversimplified it
but I hope it hasn't been too
oversimplified because at a certain
point distillation becomes a form of
deception that's true when it comes to
the life and times of Kylie Jenner but
also when it comes to much larger news
stories and this isn't only a problem on
reddit I mean all over the place
headlines misrepresented the truth I get
that nuance isn't as likely to generate
a hundred twenty-nine thousand up votes
as outrage but until it is we're gonna
be swimming in a lot of misinformation
Hank I'll see you on Friday